-Welcome back, J.B.
How are you?
-[ Laughs ]
Come on, man.
Some things you got to ask jus
because that's what
a good, wholesome dude asks,
"How you doin"?
Hey, man, I'm taking it
one day at a time,
'cause this is -- we are
in the midst of some craziness
but we will
get through this, man.
Hey, I haven't seen you
since all this started.
-I know.
-You look beautiful.
-Thank you.
Well, I will say, you know
I feel very, uh, ragged
since you last saw me.
I'm not in a suit
My hair's long,
and yet you look as good
as the last time
I laid eyes on you.
-Hey, man.
Look at the beard.
The beard is coming in nice.
-Yeah.
-If I turn my whole head
upside down,
I've got a head full of hair
and a big old chin.
You know what I mean?
[ Both laugh ]
-Now, I do appreciate you,
one, dressing up,
and, two, you're making a --
you're departing
from your schedule,
because I've heard that,
in the Smoove household,
you guys have naked Thursday
during the pandemic.
-Oh, today --
as a matter of fact, Seth,
today is naked Thursday.
You know, this is
a remarkable thing
that I have thought up because I
am not the boss of my home
I am just a manager of my house.
And that's what a man should do.
He should never be the boss.
I'm the manager.
So I created these little --
these little destinations,
I should say,
and naked Thursday
is one of them.
So, you know,
throughout this interview,
I'm gonna start
getting undressed.
Today is naked Thursday,
so don't mind me.
We're gonna keep on talking.
So...
-Now, do you structure
other days in your week?
Is it only naked Thursday,
or are there other days
that are special?
-You got to realize, Seth, the
world's in a different place
Who knows what day it is?
Only reason --
The only thing I can remembe
in my whole --
in the whole week
is naked Thursday.
Hey, this whole thing
should be shorter.
It should all be shorter.
You know,
we don't need weekends no more
Who needs weekends?
We don't need weekends no more
We just need
a certain amount of days.
Who made the calendar up?
We made the calendar up.
So we can change the calendar.
-[ Laughs ]
-In this world
we live in right now,
there is no reason
to have a damn calendar
or days of the week.
Seth, we don't need it, Seth
All we need is a few days, jus
do what we would normally do
A few nice little days
just to -- just to pass things
You know,
you need naked Thursday.
You need two days to yourself.
Two days for yourself.
Now, my wife and I, we --
now, you got to agree to this.
You can't just make it up and do
it because you get in trouble.
But my wife and I agreed tha
we have two days to ourselves.
Now, we call these days --
You get two days to get
the [bleep] out my face.
-[ Laughs ]
-We get two days to get
the [bleep] out my face.
So, everybody needs
two days to themselves.
-Yeah.
-Her to go out, you know,
and enjoy herself, you know,
get her nails done
in the house or whatever.
You can't go anywhere,
but that allows you your tim
to yourself, you see?
-Yes.
-You need two days if you want
to talk to your buddies
on the phone or on the Zoom.
You want to do
your own little thing.
You get two days to get th
[bleep] out my face, see?
But you got to agree to it
-Gotcha.
-You don't do it in the process,
just make it up one day.
You say that,
or you get in trouble, man
I've seen people
get divorced over
"get the [bleep]
out my face," too.
-[ Laughs ]
And what about -- Could I --
[ Laughs ]
Were you stocked up
for the pandemic?
Were you ready for this?
-Oh, man.
I got -- I'm a snack guy, see?
I got a lot of snacks and stuff.
So I just keep on
doing my snacks.
I get my snacks out.
See, I'm a morsel guy.
-A morsel?
-I'm a morsel guy.
-A morsel guy.
-I don't want to do a full meal.
Seth, I don't need a full meal
I can survive on morsels.
I'm a morsel guy.
I like small bites.
-What's the difference
between a snack and a morsel
Like, if I came over, and
you put out a tray of morsels,
what would be on the tray?
-Well, a morsel is a little bi
more than a little bit.
That's a little bit.
That's a morsel.
-That's a little bit.
That's a little bit.
That's a morsel.
-So the "mor" in "morsel"
is just referring to more?
That means, just like,
more than a nothing?
-You know what?
Yeah, exactly.
A morsel -- you know who knows
about the morsels the most
Is the Keebler elves.
Now, those guys,
they are famous.
Seth, those guys are famou
for their morsels.
You know, a little morsel
of chocolate.
Little morsel here and there
Now, that is how
you could live your life.
You won't gain weight.
You won't get too heavy.
-Gotcha.
-The same thing as a pinch
You ever heard of a smidgen?
-Yep.
-Now, a smidgen is a little bi
less than a pinch.
A pinch --
These are all measurements
-Yeah.
-Variables for measuring thing
that people have used
over the years, you know.
A pinch, a smidgen,
a sip, a swig.
You know what a swig is?
A swig is like -- that's a swig.
-What's a sip?
-Sip -- That's a sip.
A swig is like this.
Whap, whap, whap, whap.
That's a swig.
-This is so helpful.
-And the classic chugalug.
You know what a chugalug is?
-A chugalug? Yes.
Show me a chugalug.
-Now, you don't chugalug
a glass.
You chugalug a two-liter bottl
of your favorite beverage.
-Gotcha.
-A chugalug only works --
Over 2 liters
is when you do a chugalug.
-I see.
So, technically, you canno
chugalug from a glass becaus
it's too small amount of liquid.
-No, it's too small
of amount of liquid, you know?
Hey, if you've got a big mouth
a good swig will definitel
clear out a glass that size,
you know?
[ Laughs ]